flippy from
indiana flippy from indiana please
unmute you are
on the air my friend hi can you hear me
yes i can
hey david it's me um i just was
wondering if you've ever reconsidered
making it only fans
sorry if i if i've done making an
omelette what no no making it only fans
uh you know
uh burning season is over and it's time
for you to show us your zucchini
that's very clever no listen um i think
i'd i'd be more likely
uh i'd be more likely to show my my
granny smith apples than any zooks
floppy dukes flippy floppy uh floppy
dukes
floppy dukes flippy floppy
five and a quarter inches in the name of
jesus from south america
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here
they're coming here from africa
i hear the sound of victory
[Music]
i hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of victory
i hear the sound of winning winning
winning
[Music]
winning winning winning
by david jones is his running mate the
most liberal
senator in america
kamala
senator kamala harris
democrat kamala
if you have a pre-existing condition
heart disease
diabetes breast cancer they're coming
for you
if you love someone who has a
pre-existing condition thank you
[Music]
thank you there is so much about what
comes out of donald trump's mouth
don't be rude that is designed to
distract the american people
from what he is doing every day they
want to go out and they want to touch
they want to vote
i'm working my ass off here i'm soaking
wet already
suppression balls you can't hold them
i'm soaking wet already
suppression falls now yesterday we had
three big ones really big
suppression balls don't give me the
umbrella i'm soaking wet already
they put numbers you know they're called
suppression suppression balls
they make you like feel badly so you say
to your wife or you say to your husband
darling let's go out to dinner and then
we'll come back we love our president
but you know the polls say he can't win
well right now we're leading
in almost everywhere the real we're
leading
soaking wet already suppression falls
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and
leaders and gentlemen for freedom and
liberty and the american dream
the best is yet to come
stand back and stand by
let's please continue on person woman
man camera tv
[Music]
they didn't bother to interview a single
witness just like you
they don't want to know the truth well
you probably know the truth
okay so so there's rudy passing gas
but the content of this was also
disgusting this went on for hours
[Music]
[Music]
they didn't bother to interview a single
witness just like you
they don't want to know the truth well
you probably know the truth
i'd say that poll book is off by over a
hundred thousand
that poll book why don't you look at the
registered voters on there
how many registered voters are on there
[Music]
all right everybody okay that's enough
that's the we've probably had enough of
that
particularly on such a special special
day uh
like it is today yes people in the chat
already asking and sending birthday
super chats
it actually is my birthday today it's
very common that people
send super chats saying happy birthday
on random days
because then other people fall forward
and you know so on and so forth
um but uh it's all it's all very much
happening and i can see people are very
very excited i see
danny and kelsey and ej sending birthday
super chats
nug wrangler is gifting subs like they
are
uh trump's pardons or bribes i guess
um so yes it is all happening and we
have quite quite quite
an agenda for today joe biden will be
announcing some moves on immigration at
the top of the hour
and we'll be signing executive orders so
that's what we're standing by for
i have a few uh birthday related memes
and elements i have
two voicemails from jimmy from philly
we've not heard from him for a very long
time part of the reason is he's calling
a number we don't even use we
he's somehow leaving voicemails with a
number we closed
six weeks ago if i didn't know any
better i'd think he was some kind of
um of tech savant but we've seen video
of him so we know that that's not the
case it
must just be that you can leave
voicemails at the number even though we
closed it i don't know um but uh
it's all somehow i have two voicemails
from jimmy for you
i have a couple of video clips that i
want to go over
i don't even know where to start to be
perfectly frank
i see people on twitch very excited
about the hype train
and we are uh standing by
for elements of governance i guess is
the way i would say it
cooper says happy birthday everybody hit
the like button
azzeem says happy birthday wendy
says felix which would be like happy
birthdays
which is interesting very interesting
ben sends
mazeltov sean says happy birthday
peppy asks about the birthday cake
did i see shadow oh groundhog day right
yes i did see my shadow kelsey says
happy birthday
danny says i encourage those watching to
match my super chat amount today wow
that's a big challenge from danny
danny's
danny's great danny's been around the
show for a while
danny is if i recall correctly a website
member twitch sub
youtube member and regular super chatter
very strong 37 super chat i encourage
people to do exactly
what danny is saying um
thank you for your rad videos jacob
getting in on the action
r9 9000 do a birthday only fans
there's an idea birthday only fans would
be something to look at
pretty pretty strongly okay so listen as
far as birthday gifts
uh the team the whole team meaning
um pat max and noah
got me my very own vaccinated
face mask as many of you who
are members know i was really strongly
vaccinated
i was on a waitlist on an on-call list
and i got a vaccination moderna
first dose it put me down for the
weekend
fever the whole thing new study
suggests strong dose one reaction
implies higher likelihood of previous
asymptomatic
infection um i do think
that my girlfriend and i believe we may
have had covid back in january or
february of 2020
very light just some shortness of breath
and a cough
and of course this is not proof not
proof
but my very very powerful
reaction to the first dose you are about
from my reading of the data um three
times more likely to get a fever after
the first dose
if you already have antibodies so
who the hell knows i'm still getting my
second dose and once i get once it's
been seven days after dose two
i will very proudly wear my vaccinated
now i don't know if wearing this around
will make people
more comf comfortable being around me or
mad
in some way or if it'll piss off
anti-vaxxers i don't really know
thanks to astro lycos for gifting 10
subs i appreciate that so a very nice
custom
gift from the guys a producer noah did a
little extra he did a little compilation
with a number of mimetic elements let's
look at this let me make sure
that we have all the right volume um
oh and and the birthday gifts keep
coming in stephanie says felix
you don't have to be so formal with me
uh stephanie referring to me in a very
formal
formal tense i don't really like pie but
i love
flan and chocolate cake
um david why give jimmy from philly
airtime we want a positive live stream
not q anon on your wonderful show well
we haven't heard from him for a while
uh chris bonucci oh chris bonucci says
hey uh happy birthday can't believe you
don't like magic the gathering yeah that
was pretty uh pretty controversial
cali wants me to show my granny smiths
i've got a whole uh
i've got a whole bag of them upstairs
you should see what's going on here okay
here is the birthday
custom video from producer noah let's
take a listen
i think you've been watching a little
too much david pakman on online
whoa aggressive
making personal grooming sacrifices to
help the show that's true
raising awareness about gay teen suicide
yeah this i i
we're not joking about gay teen suicide
when it happens it's a tragedy
but somehow i ended up featured in a
documentary about
bullied gay teen suicide where
i was i was 27 at the time but somehow i
ended up in a movie about
myself portrayed as a bullied
gay teen who committed suicide died by
suicide i'm sorry
um okay anyway so that's included
[Music]
there we go oh god
very strong ink endorsements
[Music]
[Music]
and a 50 donation was made in my honor
to the massachusetts rivers alliance so
a very very nice video
um from producer noah for my birthday
very
very exciting stuff
all right aski with a dessert question
asking my opinion on trellicious
i am not a big fan i am not a i want a
proper flan a proper flan
you can take it or leave it take it or
leave it sinful solutions matching danny
with a 37 super chat for my birthday
very very nice
very very nice um okay so we got
that out of the way um
oh oh oh my god i can't believe also i'm
forgetting to thank other people
i do want to thank 24 people very very
early
in the stream signing up via twitch
i also want to say thanks to austin king
eugene vernikov
and stephanie reynolds for signing up at
joinpacman.com i appreciate that and i
see a lot of
arguments in the chat about uh various
birthday gifts
the best birthday gift is to get a
membership at joinpackman.com we had a
tough january from the perspective of
memberships
so i would love it if uh people grabbed
some
peanut noir says okay but what about the
superior south american dessert
alfajores of course of course i am still
looking
to try let me see if i can find this
there's this new really
strongly dark there's an extra dark
havana
apparently now i've not tried this i
think it's this one this is not you know
because of the pandemic and
all that stuff i guess i could just
order it this thing
this is not one that i've tried but a 70
cacao coating that is powerful
and see how it's referred to as a
luxurious alpha
that's i believe that i believe that
this is what i'm looking forward to
trying uh next time in argentina i know
i can probably order it off amazon but i
like to pretend like it's hard to get
these items you know
um okay very good so we got that
um and then do you guys want me to go
to wait what's this
oh oh oh oh hey listen to this this is
interesting
i was looking through twitch analytics
after yesterday's abortive stream i was
trying to figure out looking at
analytics what went wrong
and um there's an area where it tells
you
like where your viewers come from
and for me these three channels which
i'm not familiar with
are listed as my top three i guess
like are these channels that are sending
me viewers
or channels with whom i share viewers
does anybody know what this even means
nobody knows
share viewers oh that's interesting
let's look let's see what
some of these are here hold on twitch.tv
stock guy i don't know what this stuff
is
let's see if stock guy is live offline
let's look at videos no videos found oh
my god so i don't know what stock guy is
let's see what else we've got here
central committee
central committee let's see what this is
about
central committee uh are there any
videos
okay i don't even know what this is
about let's see
and i'm not even hearing anything over
muted
250 million in a ladder attack to happen
i thought all these hedge funds oh hold
on did i look at the wrong thing oh it's
the stock guy
oh my god i'm so sorry okay so this is
central committee
the stock guy let's see what we've got
here
the stock guy here's why you doing
uh let's do this let's get it going
let's get it going
what's your opinion on a good stop-loss
on starbucks i don't put stop-losses on
my long-term hold
okay warning
this twitch stream might crash in five
minutes and 44 seconds
okay so there's stock guy
and mr mooten mouton
mr mouton i share viewers with
let's see only to subscribers well i
can't
uh subscribe see if we have any clips
can i see any of these no subscribers
only all right well
i don't know what mouton is maybe a
highlight no subscribers only
all right well in any case those are the
three i don't even know what any of this
stuff means but i guess the three
channels with whom
it just doesn't make sense because my
top referrers
are hassan and destiny
and gotham chess so like
i don't even really know what this means
yeah anyway these were the top ones and
then there's a whole bunch at three
percent
and stuff like that okay so you know it
is what it is
i don't i don't really know what else to
uh what else to say
um okay thanks to samuel mitchell for
signing up at joinedpakman.com denise
engelhardt
rob silver and adam bieber all of whom
signed up at joinpakman.com putting us
at 31
also big thanks to four new twitch subs
dc subi sumi long
havana and
louie curtin for signing up via twitch
i appreciate that as well okay matty
sancho says please read my previous
comment
let's see did biden really ban fracking
on federal land and how far does it
actually go
is it in the works to be permanent and
happy birthday all right i i will look
into that
i will look into that oh did i miss
another 37
contribution no there was danny's
there was sinful
and there was i think that's it yeah
happy birthday pacman you made it easier
to get through 2020 thanks for your show
i hear the sound of victory
i hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of rain
yes flan
felix okay thank you hey pacman it's my
wife
and i nine year anniversary can you give
us a shout out our names are ashley and
garrick
grosso happy birthday man yes happy
ninth anniversary
and i actually have another i missed
this yesterday
and i feel terribly about it there was
an engagement
that took place during yesterday's
stream via super chat and i didn't even
know because we were watching
kenzie wrote to me yesterday david i'm
not sure if you saw your super chats
during your latest live stream
but my boyfriend proposed to me on your
show we watch you every day
you have been a source of happiness
throughout the pandemic and the trump
era
we would love it if you would give us a
shout out in your next show yes
kenzie congratulations on the engagement
um i also bought a membership through
your website
absolutely uh it's kenzie and jake
congratulations to kenzie
and jake jake proposing to kenzie via
super chat yesterday
i don't know the backstory i'm just
telling you what i know
if you're ordained please officiate our
wedding once covet is
over of course i am ordained but i can
only do
uh orthodox jewish weddings so
you know i don't know what to sort of uh
you know let me know if that would fit
with what you guys have going on
big thank you to michael green
greenhalgh
ashley matson and christine saylor for
signing up at joinpackman.com
one other thing um if we have any of our
great
uh song parody composers in the stream
today
i have an idea now i'm an idea guy i'm
not an execution guy because i don't
know how to do songs
but i like the idea of somebody doing a
remix of the song
jolene with jolene replaced with vaccine
me talking about my vaccine i think that
that would be interesting with other
elements
from my vaccine story from the bonus
show dropped in
i had that idea today um
if if anybody wants to take that jethro
bradley or joe woodward or
or any of our you know different great
people dj physic
uh and all of those people that would be
that would be really great
um people asking how i got the vaccine
again i've mentioned this a bunch of
times
i got on a list for on what's called an
on-call list for leftover doses
this means that at the end of the day as
many of you know you know there's these
vials that come with six doses in them
a bunch of people who qualify get
scheduled
right um once that's open it's open you
have to use it within a certain period
of time
many hospitals have on-call lists where
if it gets to be 8 p.m and they've got a
dose left
they will call someone and at that point
it's like whoever can come in just in
order of you being on the list all right
everybody take it easy
everybody relax um
okay okay let's get to the jimmy
from philly voicemails i have not
pre-screened these we've not heard from
jimmy for a while
he is a very angry trumpist recently
arrested
and so on oh thanks turtle for gifting
10 subscriptions
jimmy somehow keeps calling our old
phone number which has been shut down
for six weeks
i don't know how he keeps leaving
voicemails at it but somehow he does
let's listen to it and i may shut it
down you know if it gets too
too aggressive i will shut it down give
me some philly
white do you progress what does that
mean does he say
white like he's is he announcing his
race jimmy from philly white
this is fail with brandy oh my god you
just failed every [ __ ] thing
you you fail at picking your leaders my
god bernie sanders was cheated
twice by his own party but there's no
such thing as voter fraud
there's no such thing as people cheating
in elections
there's no such thing i think jimmy's
teething i think that's what's going on
right you people are idiots
and somehow somehow
he has managed to sustain riots over the
country
what the left is sustaining riots
has he paid any attention to politics
that maybe a lot of these trump people
checked out
um i don't know for almost a year
there was no problem with these riots
they were peaceful protesters mostly
what was all this [ __ ] billions of
dollars in damage 30
people killed and yet when a few
goofball trump supporters
lost the capital oh that's rich all
right so we're going to cut that one off
and then he left another one a couple
days after jimmy from zoe
white uh you need to take a poll
on david scheuer's hair
david sure what the hell is he talking
about
i mean really david you expect us to
did the dudes rock in he's oh oh oh i
think he's talking about my guest last
week david shore i guess he had
long hair i don't even remember his hair
he's got a.d
dairies on like popcorn jesus christ you
think he could develop a relationship
with a comb
what wow so really really incisive
commentary that
there from uh from jimmy from philly
all right if you're just joining us
we're standing by let's see if we have a
white house stream yet
uh we don't uh but we should soon
we're standing by for joe biden at the
top of the hour he's gonna tell us what
he's doing on immigration
and what what the plan is going forward
i do want to
say thank you to everybody who's been
sending 37
super chats i guess this is danny
thompson started this
uh 37 super chats for my birthday today
brooks says happy birthday david thank
you for helping get me through the
pandemic while living with trumpists
that sounds tough that sounds tough
artist alfonso says happiest of
birthdays david remember you're not a
year older you're another year awesome
nice atheist linguist says what do you
think the odds are of aoc running for
president in 2014. nope i'm out as i
said i only talk about the next election
i only talk which is 22 right now sam
says thank you for introducing me to kim
stanley robinson just finished reading
red mars and it was incredible yeah i've
been
i've been on a kick with kim stanley
robinson i recently
read read mars i read the three
californias it's three different
novels written over about an eight year
period taking place in
different future californias and i'm
right in the thick
of um the the ministry
for the future right now recommended by
uh former president barack obama
the book didn't make trump's top 20
books of 2020.
i'm sure trump read tons of books in
2020 and this was just not one of his
top 20.
but it did make barack obama's top 20
list of books they both read a ton of
books i'm sure
um okay
can i give a shout out to my daughter
mary it's also her birthday today yes
samuel happy birthday to me to mary
and to shakira very very important
birthdays today david read twitch chat
we can answer these questions i i read
twitch chat guys
we're not doing that again are we um mr
mouton
streams with destiny destiny has history
with all three of them ask him too
okay good very very good love to hear
that
all right thank you to the 10
folks who just signed up via twitch um
oh that's the 10 subs that turtle gifted
very much appreciate that
and also want to thank a couple of other
people wayne
sugihara just signed up at
joinpackman.com
nicolas aboutis no that's
just signed up at joinedpakman.com lily
cougar
the duck of death and gabriel ordonez
as well as uh phillip hayes all signing
up at joinedpakman.com
appreciate that the coupon code uh
is in play the coupon code is in play
have i heard any updates regarding nina
turner if she's still up in the polls no
i have no idea
no i don't know anything about that what
are the odds marjorie taylor green loses
or wins in 2022
no idea yet there is our a
favorite non-authoritarian socialist
vaash who is checking in with a
37 uh dollar birthday super chat great
to see you um
i know him as chris but most people know
him by his pseudonym
vosh uh no but we we we love vosh i am
not a socialist but we had a great great
conversation or
i know i'm supposed to say it vouch and
pretend i don't know how to say it
uh no but it's great to see you chris
that's a joke by the way it's not really
chris
we we said before it's actually zach
speaking of zack by the way tragic
tragic news about the passing of dustin
diamond
i grew up with fresh prince of bel-air
and saved by the bell family matters
um those were really my big three
and a dustin diamond who played screech
three weeks ago i know a lot of people
saying he wasn't a great guy okay yeah
forget it
forget it just it's a part of my
childhood diagnosed
with uh cancer three weeks ago and he's
gone
absolutely absolutely horrible
oh man go on
the stream one day yeah okay
is it too late for tulsi
too late for what it's not too late for
her to get a uh
a fox news gig seems to be going very
very quickly in that direction um
yeah i watched full house a little bit
as well
yeah but fresh prince of bel-air and
saved by the bell were just
you know those were those were just the
tops i remember you know even back then
i was eating granny smith apples i'd
have a granny smith apple sliced up
after school and watched saved by the
bell
um those were really the days
those were really the days i see people
talking to me about
the jeff bezos news i've not read about
it yet
so um i'm gonna wait to learn more about
it yeah boy meets world i watched as
well
seinfeld was later seinfeld was later
never watched andy griffith show or
anything like that no
no no no if i really yeah i mean it was
saved by the bell and uh
uh fresh prince were the tops never
watched wonder years
never i think that was before my time
okay how the expletive are you 37
looking 26
i don't know that i'm not sure about
that would i consider appearing on tyts
the damage report
absolutely i don't think that i don't
think john would have me
i don't think he really has people i'm
not sure exactly who his guests tend to
be
but i don't like john and i do the same
thing and i don't know that he really
tends to have
people i mean maybe he does i don't know
but i would be glad to appear
what's an effective tactic of debating a
guy like ben shapiro
oh okay so the best tactic for debating
guys like ben shapiro who talk really
fast and in a confident manner is you
you slow it way down like you you
you need a setting in which you can
control the pace of the conversation
or a moderator that will control it for
you and you have to slow it way down
and you have to focus on one point at a
time ben does a lot of gish galloping
which is throwing a bunch of stuff at
you at once that all
sort of maybe sounds coherent and you've
got to
slow it down and say okay hold but hold
on you made three different points there
let's go through them one at a time
and unfortunately a lot of uh
a lot of settings don't make that
possible
and so it can be very very tough to do
what are my thoughts on republicans not
wanting to have a trial
and lindsey graham threatening to bring
in the fbi i don't care
i don't care would you debate jimmy dore
about what i mean like i like i often
say if there's a coherently
focused debate with a format that will
be controlled
i'm certainly up for it have i watched
british progressives navara media
i have not callie says don't slice your
granny smiths
how else do you put peanut butter on it
or dulce de leche
i don't know um
okay we've got that all right let me get
to a couple i did have a couple of clips
i wanted to play for you this is very
funny people are finally starting to ask
other republicans what they think about
the in
insanity that's coming out of the mouth
of marjorie taylor greene
and they're all saying really dumb stuff
here is steve scalise
asked about marjorie taylor green
somehow to ends up talking about
chinese carbon marjory taylor green the
freshman congresswoman from
georgia under some fire for past
comments i'm going to be meeting with
majority minority leader kevin mccarthy
later and
liz cheney is going to have to talk to
some of her
members on the republican side who would
like to see her
removed from her leadership position
because of supporting impeachment and
voting for that
based on your conversations are more of
your members supportive
of green or cheney well first of all
i've rejected those statements by
marjorie and you know i think
uh we're going to be talking tomorrow in
conference we're going to have an
in-person meeting
in the capitol where we're going to be
talking through a lot of these issues
internally
uh look first of all we're very united
in our opposition
to the devastating economic hits that
president biden has been doing in his
first
week's comparison what on earth is he
talking about devastating
economic hits perpetrated by joe by what
what on earth is this guy talking about
and then he goes into chinese carbon we
haven't even talked about
we'll crush american manufacturing and
send it to china where they make five
times more carbon
to make things like steel that
pennsylvania will not be able to make
if they get that so we're going to be
talking do you uh do you support the
things that marjorie taylor green has
said
why aren't we talking about the economic
hits that joe biden has perpetrated on
this what are you talking about
and then here's another one here is
supposedly
rational centrist republican nancy mace
and she does it both sides she says
listen there's crazy people on both
sides
but there are crazies on both sides of
the aisle we've seen that
um you know it's not just republicans
that have our own issues at least she's
calling marjorie taylor green crazy
democrats have them too we've seen
maxine waters
tell folks to go and threaten and harm
members of the
trump administration right we've seen
crazies on both sides of the aisle
we do have to i think address some of
these issues but you know some of these
things and i'm learning about them today
and this week too were said
both sides guys yeah both sides um uh
did you guys hear when bernie talked
about catholic space lasers it's crazy
he burned the wildfires on
bernie being jewish is it going to blame
it on jewish space lasers and
it's all the same you've got all this
stuff on both sides it's really quite a
quite quite a situation both sides guys
so i'll be covering that tomorrow
and um it's completely nuts
i don't understand why we don't have a
feed from the white house yet but we are
standing by here
for joe biden to tell us what he's doing
on immigration in the form of an
emergency
and uh we should be hearing from him
very very soon
i want to say thank you to aaron sososky
i hope i'm pronouncing that correctly
for signing up at joinpackman.com
um super chats are coming in pepe xanadu
says what is your birth best birthday
memory
my best birthday memory
maybe when i turned 16 and could get my
learner's permit to drive
i mean i don't know there's nothing
nothing stands out so maybe that that
was a long time ago
um yes it really it really is my
birthday yes and we've got a lot of
people
um grabbing memberships to celebrate
thanks to jeff waldorf for raiding with
a party of 13 appreciate that
jeff always great to uh always great to
hear
from jeff very very exciting
kazeem says devastating has he heard of
the great recession yeah very very weird
ashley says happy birthday david back
told the people says in reference to
yesterday's voicemail
i think you would appreciate king of the
hills satire of american culture
most of it is aged well yeah if you guys
missed yesterday's
bonus show there was a really funny
bonus show i not being a king of the
hill guy
i didn't recognize this but then people
told me this is uh this is a character
from king of the hill take a listen to
this
yeah i don't tell you what man i don't
have enough your daniel level [ __ ]
man is you know
you you vote for hillary man you were
done voting for benghazi and man
[ __ ] like you got like they're her email
man of the events the hell that's going
on like they don't even got me her email
and [ __ ] man
i don't even give a [ __ ] man like you
know daniel cunanan
man [ __ ] the police man there you go so
that
um i mean it's brilliantly done once we
actually listened to uh
boomhauer from king of the hill
it all started to make a lot of sense
but
i i had no frame of reference did i hear
about anti-vaxxers shutting down
dodger stadium yeah we talked about it
on today's bonus show it's completely
bonkers so
out of this world we really uh
indicative of major major problems in
this country
other countries have anti-vaxxers as
well but i'm familiar more familiar with
the um
anti-vaxx problem in the united states
uh people asking where it was is joe
biden i have no idea
um let's see what other streams there
are
uh upcoming live streams live now
washington post is live let's see what
they've got
they don't have any live video though
let's see
who else might be live whoops
uh looks like that's kind of it upcoming
live streams
we've got the fox news yeah i don't know
what the delay is
i genuinely don't know pbs newshour has
a feed
yeah so everybo it's the same situation
everywhere
so we'll see they should get they should
start pretty soon it was scheduled for
eight minutes ago
they tend not to be uh super late so we
will see
greetings mr very much on sex david
pakman wow
eduardo says if trump follows through
with starting his patriot party
will it delu it will dilute the
republican voting pool and make it
easier for democrats to be elected
um i hope so yeah and i had a very funny
trump dance
video that i was actually going to play
for you guys where was this
yeah this somebody sent this to me
because we have time let's take a look
this is a trump dance compilation
[Music]
i love it
[Music]
[Music]
it's legendary it really is
[Music]
there it is
obvi like there's no question he's done
that while
observing women with jeffrey epstein in
some condo right like there's no
question whatsoever
[Music]
hahaha
imagine being this guy right now
[Music]
so anyway there is one term president uh
donald trump doing
a number of different dances there and
uh very very exciting stuff
uh okay delay is biden being briefed
about your birthday that could be
that could be yep mr nasty says david
you missed my 10
super chat i'm sorry i do the best i can
um hey david happy birthday also it's my
girlfriend's birthday can i get a shout
out to
yasmin we both love your show and has
been a huge help introducing her to
politics absolutely happy birthday
yasmin
very much appreciate that and glad
you're here
thank you mr nasty very important stuff
andres says mike judge creator of king
of the hill and other pop culture icons
is ecuadorian like myself is that true
mike judge wiki he's from ecuador i've
not heard that before
um okay
imagine that he's the middle of three
children
born to buh-buh-buh-buh-buh divers birth
foreign
oh okay no but he was born he was born
to american parents
it's sort of like john mccain was born
in panama to say mike judge is
ecuadorian is a bit of a stretch
it's a bit of a bit of a stretch uh
legally he may be
he he certainly may be but you know it's
sort of like uh
it's almost like a diplomatic type of
thing it still counts it's still
interesting yeah no question about it
but
okay very very exciting tommy says
people who were born in february are the
best i can say that because my
birthday's on the 18th and my daughters
is the 28th happy birthday david love
your show
thanks very much tommy i appreciate that
happy birthday david parkman says joe
larocca
appreciate that thank you um
okay yeah i know about the tucker
carlson stuff people wanted me to review
it
i guess i'd be willing to do it it looks
like we've still got a little bit of
time
let me see here tucker carlson
fox news channel democrats mobilized
yeah here it is okay let's let's check
it out
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy monday
the news is moving with bewildering
speed in case you haven't noticed we've
noticed
no presidential administration has ever
changed so many
basic institutions and facts of american
life
okay he's already lying to you it's
already horrible
and done it so quickly he promised to do
stuff and he's doing it
we've done our best to bring you nightly
updates on what's happening for the week
and a half that joe biden has been
president but at times it's over imagine
framing the fact that biden quickly
jumped into action as a bad thing
overwhelming there's just too much to
cover
the other day for example we learned
that the biden administration plans to
make the tiny
district of columbia our 51st state
plans to wants to
plans to come on a more corrupt
english-speaking version
of monaco as if lobbyists and washington
didn't have enough control so this is
the fake populism
understand this is the fake oh monaco
for those
rich people to hide their little love
this is tucker's fake populism
all over your life it's not even fake
it's just right-wing populism which is
horrible
now they'll be u.s senators but that's
not even the biggest news
just a few hours ago biden officials
informed us that after almost
65 years of working to build a nuclear
weapon
the nation of iran may be finally and
you'll find this amazing
quote just weeks away from getting a
bomb
well yeah trump backed out of the deal
so they went back to research obviously
after 65 years of trying what a
coincidence
oh is he trying to say it's because
biden's here
there were already reports during the
trump presidency
because trump bailed on the deal that
they were going back to re
trump's like hey okay you guys didn't
even violate the deal but we're out of
it because i don't like it
they obviously go back to research and
now
12 days into biden's presidency tucker's
like hey look they're
they're close to a weapon now you
already know how that story is going to
end
another pointless foreign war trillions
spent many dead
the united states gaining nothing we've
seen that a lot
and it's happening again joe biden just
sent american troops to syria
well you didn't know that yep hours
after he became president
american soldiers crossed into the
nation of syria sending them to syria
was one of the first things joe biden
did
somehow most of the media forgot to even
mention that well that's an
extraordinarily myopic
framing of what took place in their
defense as noted there's a lot going on
in the news including a lot of troop
mobilization
syria is not the only place they're
massing washington dc looks like
occupied sarajevo
and why are they there you know there we
saw these trumpists who were saying let
me just check on the
on the biden thing just to see what's
going on um
there were a bunch of trumpets who were
interviewed around the time of the
inauguration and they were saying
dc's like a war zone
dc is not a war zone because it's run by
democrats dc became a war zone because
on january 6th
trumpists tried an insurrection
tonight a small city overflowing with
soldiers
the troops came last month tens of
thousands of them
we were told they're going to protect
the capital from the inevitable
right-wing violence
they were there because of the violence
on the sixth
to accompany joe biden's inauguration
well there
fortunately what imagine what he's doing
he's pretending that they were there to
prevent violence that didn't happen
because it was never going to happen
they were there
because there was violence on january
6th
thanks to their presence there wasn't
violence on january 20th but
if you just watch tucker and don't think
about this stuff for yourself you would
never know that
then joe biden was inaugurated and there
wasn't any violence donald trump
because they were there trump didn't
chain himself to north portico
trump voters didn't rush the stage the
trump
they didn't rush the stage well there
were multiple perimeters
how could they have rushed the stage
restoration never happened
and yet the troops stayed
no one in congress seemed to notice but
in fact they're still arriving as of
tonight
thousands of them as of last thursday
national guard troops from 23 states
were stationed in washington
that number seems to have risen over the
past few days we called the national
guard today to find out by how much but
they couldn't give us numbers or
wouldn't
we do know that more states have sent
troops since last week
you may have seen the video of soldiers
getting off buses downtown near the
capitol
what are they all doing there again
national guard leadership wouldn't tell
us
quote for operational security reasons
the spokesman said we will not get into
specific
details of the ongoing mission oh
soldiers in our capital but we don't
have a right to know got it
well they won't tell fox news ahead of
time
is different than no one ever has a
right to know jb pritzker who's the
governor of illinois was not so shy
about the purpose he laid it out very
clearly
in a press release announcing the
deployment of more soldiers to
washington d.c
pritzker explained that quote we must
root out the dark forces of racism
white supremacy and disinformation that
have created this moment
let that sink in the military has been
deployed to washington dc
to fight disinformation i mean obviously
that's not the case so that's very very
dumb
so say something a democratic governor
doesn't like and he will send troops
does that sound like the country it's
kind of dumb to send them to dc where
there are very few republicans if the
idea is to punish republicans
this is all extraordinarily stupid as
i'm sure many of you can
tell we're just keeping an eye on the
joe biden thing we don't know why it's
running so late
let's continue that you grew up in it
probably doesn't
this is not the way things are done in
america it's not the way they have been
done
since the civil war no one alive has
ever seen
anything like this so why is everyone
everyone pretending it's totally normal
to have thousands of troops in the
capital to fight disinformation
well the fight disinformation thing i i
don't even i don't know if pritzker
misspoke
but to base an entire segment on that
seems pretty dumb
the really disingenuous part is ignoring
the fact that the reason troops went in
the first place was because of the
trumpist riot on january 6th
notice that he never mentioned anything
here
about the actual violence on january 6th
which is the catalyst for all of this
that's notably missing from this segment
we're four minutes in
because obviously they're in favor of it
they think it's fine to mobilize the
army in order to put down
domestic opinions yeah and so
he's ignoring the part about white
supremacy
this is really weaponized msnbc though
let us remind you an opinion channel is
completely in favor of this
watch and now nearly 5 000 national
guard troops will be deployed in d.c
through march as some congressional
staffers and extremism researchers say
there are concerns about possible
violence surrounding the upcoming
impeachment proceedings
okay well i mean i that that's true i
have
friends at multiple um
organizations that track hate groups and
they're all very worried about violence
surrounding the impeachment
the national guard will have to stay
there as a symbol to those people who
think that that building is vulnerable
and that includes the american citizens
who went up there
and performed insurrection inside the
pentagon's decision
to keep thousands of national guard
troops in the streets of washington d.c
as we get a new gut punch from the fbi
affirming the greatest threat facing the
american people
is already among us oh extremism
researchers
so the southern poverty law center is
now in charge of the pentagon
oh my god give me a break i don't i
don't actually think tucker believes any
of this stuff i really don't
i think tucker is much like i think
tucker is essentially a grifter
um the reality is tucker's just a rich
heir uh he he's you know
basically what he wants to do is create
a product here
um i think he's essentially an actor
yeah i don't i don't think he believes
half of the stuff or more that he says
he's developed a character
and there's lots of people in fact who
have developed characters that they play
on channels once they figure out sort of
what is profitable
uh they fall a prey to something called
audience capture you know you've heard
of regulatory capture maybe which is
when
regulatory agencies are run by the
people they're supposed to be regulating
um and and basically audience capture i
think i first heard that phrase used by
eric weinstein audience capture is
essentially when the the the audience
starts controlling what you do and what
your positions are
um and for for a lot of these grifters
who
who have had big political awakenings
and tucker hasn't so much had an
awakening
but he's certainly gone more in this
right-wing populist kind of like every
man direction
where which is where he gets this
overlap with people like jimmy dore and
glenn greenwald and others
um it's a character i don't i don't buy
it for a second
i don't i don't believe it's genuine in
any way
thanks to jeremiah maudlin who just
signed up at joinpakman.com and his new
member number 56 today
also want to say thanks to the four
people who just grabbed
subs on twitch putting us at 60
those are billy sc
pseudo spike colo lopez
and hat mumfree
hat mum free all right thank you i
appreciate that
let me do some other uh super chats oh
hold on first people are saying there
might have been an
update to the schedule let me take a
look
no this is still scheduled for five
i don't know i don't i don't know why it
hasn't started yet i really oh here we
go
very nice we have one one uh bit of
video
so i guess we're getting closer standing
by here
um okay let's go through some of these
super chats so i can get caught up bae
photo says tucker isn't even a good
bad actor outlaw the god says executive
orders for immigrants and black people
get shafted again love the show david
keep it up happy birthday bro
happy birthday david and to christy
brinkley
junie mcgraw says if dc can't be a state
because it's tiny by that logic wyoming
should revoke statehood since it has a
smaller population than dc
yes very much well said happy birthday
homeboy
viva sood america it's sood
sood s.u.d south america
when you call republicans silly and
wacky it makes my day happy birthday big
mouth oh god
i think trump has ruined the ymca song
at least that's what i think happy
birthday
an extra five bucks thank you i
appreciate that
looks like we're getting very close
let's see if anybody else is live yet no
only good thing we have this washington
post feed here let's see if there's
audio
there is some very strong
super chat from jeremiah maudlin who
says with a hundred dollar super chat
any guesses or conjecture
regarding what may or may not happen oh
my god
you gotta be kidding me what may or may
not happen with marjorie taylor green
and others i think she's not going to be
expelled
i think she might be censured i don't
think she will be expelled
because i don't think these republicans
have the will nor the testicular
fortitude
so i think she stays but hopefully will
be removed
in 2022 that's my best guess
right now let's see if that noise is
still going
no it's not okay good i am not a
democrat i've never been a democrat
i've always been uh independent
kevin says happy birthday mines tomorrow
happy birthday in advance
i feel such unbearable rage from tucker
says tristan a lot of people do yeah
alicia says what is going on here happy
birthday david welcome to the next level
in the game of life you were the reason
i started playing
chess in the last few months i love the
show it kept me sane this year thank you
and keep
being awesome thank you alicia
appreciate that
dodging rain says critical thinking
should be a core
curriculum yes
damn son says nothing better than
watching a david pakman stream
while eating some chips on the side
hey this is not a by the way this is not
an advertiser yet although i want to get
them as an advertiser because this seems
cool
i keep getting these ads on instagram
where it says here's a snack that's a
better alternative to a chip
and they are crispy salmon skins
i love this idea high in protein
and um probably to some degree does the
skin have uh
uh fatty uh uh fish oil
nobody's heard of these
anyway okay yeah i like the idea i mean
i i don't eat potato chips
i haven't had soda in a decade and and i
don't eat potato chips but crispy salmon
skin sounds
fantastic to me
wow i'm shocked that some people find
that so are there a lot of people in the
chat who are still in the like i've not
matured into liking fish phase yet
because i know not liking fish is like a
kind of
a lot of kids don't like fish you know
then eventually you learn oh fish is
great
a lot of people don't like fish got it
okay
all right happy birthday to shakira yes
shakira and i
share a birthday very exciting and we
share a native language the language of
spanish
[Music]
emma says welsh birthed i don't even
know how that's pronounced
penblood happis david welsh birthday
greetings thank you emma
andrew says apart
the aspirated s is another element and
then in general in argentinian spanish
we speak with boss now people
hear that and they're like oh i know
that i learned spanish spain spanish
it's vosotros
no bus in argentina and in uruguay
is uh has nothing to do well has nothing
to do
it has something to do it is totally
different than the spanish vosotros
very nicely said bay photo pacman gifted
six weeks of winter for his birthday
probably ashley says happy birthday
david thanks for making
last year bearable while i figure out
what's going on my pleasure
um patrick says i ate fried fish skin in
singapore a little high in salt
right uh oh which reminds me i don't
know how many of you people you know
i've said before like i don't watch any
political shows on youtube
i i follow other stuff i want to do a
couple of really great shout outs number
one
shout out to kevin from epic gardening
fantastic gardening channel he's been
giving me gardening advice
off air he's a supporter of the david
pakman show
let's support kevin from epic gardening
show up tell him you're here with peace
and love from the david pakman show
and also mark wiens
from migrationology who does great great
food related videos mostly in asia
absolutely fantastic make sure
if you follow migrationology anywhere
to tell mark wiens you are there with
peace and love from the david pakman
show we we're building community here
and um oh and
also by the way i don't know if mark i'm
not mark wiens i have no
idea whether he's aware of the david
pakman show kevin from epic gardening i
know is uh
celebrity chef and restaurateur is that
the right pronunciation restaurateur
tyler florence um
big supporter of the david pakman show
he has a youtube channel that's still
small called the
i believe it's the wolf it down test
kitchen
um if you follow tyler florence
absolutely
tell him you're there with peace and
love from the david pakman show
oh yeah and philip defranco philip
defranco also has been big
philip defranco and ethan klein from the
uh h3 podcast
also uh big supporters of the david
pakman show we want to cross pollinate
always cross-pollinate big thank you to
katherine
cowdery for signing up at
joinedpakman.com
and joseph mccraw not mcgraw but
mccraw new members number 61 and 62
today
also want to say thanks to the five
folks who just signed up on twitch
those are lil taco the goat
koiyu bonds and visual litter
appreciate that very much thanks guys
a lot of people are angry hold on who
did i just mention
that is infuriating people is it tyler
florence or is it ethan klein
who i some people are furious about
someone i just mentioned
and i can't tell who it is
people are mad i mentioned ethan klein
okay
i don't know why okay
it was the mention of lil taco okay
listen i'm sorry guys i i'm just telling
you people that are supporters of the
show
okay jill bernard says happy birthday
it's the kale chips for me love a good
kale chip
love a good kale chip you got to make
sure to go single layer
on the cookie sheet because otherwise
they will get
very flaccid for lack of a better term
you don't want that
ej says really enjoy your interview with
pennsylvania lieutenant governor john
fetterman he's the best
i've never interviewed him i don't know
who did i interview someone who looks
like him is that a joke
i have never interviewed john fetterman
i honestly i can't tell if that's a joke
because i interviewed someone who looks
like him
or if someone's just confused
yeah i'm not sure annunziata cole says
do you think the republicans are trying
to bait democrats into creating more
media
to expel marjorie taylor green only to
turn around and call them undemocratic
and turn the popular opinion in their
favor no
i don't think that's what they're trying
to do i don't think so
all right still standing by for joe
biden amanda
whoa hold on a second what did amanda
say
amanda says happy birthday my aquarian
king thank you
keep up the great work david happy
birthday says minnesota hockey girl
valerie says i love sharing a birthday
with a brilliant mind like yours
groundhog babies rock
yes although when i was where i was born
in argentina groundhog's day isn't a
thing
and i have a summer birthday there kind
of depressing
jeremiah maudlin says have you seen the
footage of the police pepper spring the
nine-year-old girl saw it on sam's
channel i may have missed it here
i didn't hear of the about the story i
didn't hear about the story
oh and we lost video what is happening
yeah i really have no idea what's going
on
it's very strange we've never had a
delay this big
with the joe biden administration 33
minutes late
atheist linguist says no soda for a
decade you poor depraved soul why would
you do that to yourself
yeah i just uh you know i oh oh oh
this reminds me of something this is so
funny um
hold on where was this i posted the
other day
hold on where did i do this okay here it
is i posted
since it appears the if you're not
following me on twitter you should
since it appears the various food
delivery and online ordering apps take a
bunch of restaurant cash and exhibit
predatory behavior
i always find the restaurant's direct
number on their own website
order directly and pick up is this a
good practice should i be doing this
i got a bunch of replies about chains
and i
i clarified for people responding
for people responding about chains i
haven't eaten at a chain restaurant
or even been to a starbucks in 18 years
this is all local restaurants
now many of you know about the kfc
incident
which is the one sort of caveat to the
this entire thing
but i you know it's hard to put that
into into just this few small number of
characters
and i got some funny responses about not
having been to chain restaurants let me
see if i can find it
um
hold on oh maybe oh we get it you're a
liberal i
i mean plenty of liberals go to chain
restaurants
um oh this is so funny david we know
about the kfc scandal that's hilarious i
didn't even realize someone had said
that
um hold on there was some other funny
ones here
hipster chain restaurants are not
actually restaurants anyways yeah
they're more like food factories
um how on earth have you avoided chains
for so long was it a conscious decision
i don't know i mean it's i'm not sure
just don't do it somebody said this is
the most pacman thing oh here it is the
most pacman tweet ever this was my
favorite response
yeah so anyway i i to me it's not been
difficult to avoid the chain restaurants
i have to tell you but i know that for a
lot of people it's a big uh
it's a big big big big thing and there's
a it seems that there's like huge
arguments sort of like ford versus chevy
where people are like oh wendy's versus
mcdonald's
i have no idea i couldn't tell you can
anybody actually
like what's the big controversy between
wendy's and mcdonald
what's the debate that people have about
which item is better at one versus the
other
fries is the debate nuggets
fries or nuggets are the debates yeah i
don't know from what i recall the fries
at wendy's
and the nuggets were better than at
mcdonald's when i was going to those
places i remember wendy's being better
on both
but uh yeah it's been too long i don't
know
anyway all right let's get let's get off
of this topic let's keep going
and we're still standing by for joe
biden
maybe this has been cancelled i have no
idea
yeah okay other super chats coming in
let's see who else is chiming in
giselle candelaria says felix appreciate
that
sasquatch hunter says wasn't the george
wasn't georgia a referendum going
without obstructionists
wasn't georgia a referendum going
without
obstructionists in other words they
voted the non-obstructionists in in
georgia yeah i think so if i understand
that
correctly chris says happy birthday
david thank you for the queen's gambit
recommendation my wife and i loved it
here's another recommendation okay this
is a
i'm going to give you two
recommendations
the netflix show french
show lupe
one of the best shows absolutely one of
the best shows it's only six episodes
we are desperately awaiting season two
french crime show what a great show
what a great show and i i actually read
about
uh four other french dramas
that look really great and i've added
them actually a couple
are not on netflix but they're on amazon
prime so that's exciting
i am almost through the first season of
bosch and amazon prime
original i didn't love it immediately
but it's grown on me quite a bit and i
like titus wellever
there's some other good actors
on the show and i think it's really
really great
uh okay oh did did vosh say something
funny that i missed i see a lot of
people
referencing all of a sudden
oh oh oh i said bosh oh again it's b o s
c b o s c h
is that right yes of course guys lupin
has subtitles
b-o-s-c-h
yeah it feels like it should be six
letters but it's but yeah bosch is a
good show
and uh it's kind of a slow burn but it's
very good i've not seen
bridgerton i don't know a thing about it
i've not seen uh the singapore show
about rich people in singapore or the
philippines i've not seen that
don't know a thing about it okay big
thank you to jose amalod
which means lover in spanish as well as
richard bach
and becky horton who just signed up at
joinedpakman.com putting us at
69 memberships today
really really strong super chat from
svelte duck who says happy birthday
from a fellow oh hold on a second
all three of us here we go secretary of
homeland security no
the got information about uh
how this happened you can't hear a thing
and uh let's try here three of whom were
injured today audio's a disaster let's
try here
one of the things when you are
in a combat zone of the military or as
loud as it goes
fbi agent or military or a police
officer
every family just when i put that
shield on and go out in the morning
dredge the possibility of a call
receiving that phone call and my heart
aches for the families i've not had an
opportunity nor will i try today
to to contact them but
they put their lives on the line and uh
it's a hell of a price to pay
and every single day every sean these
folks get up and they uh
by and large the vast vast majority of
these men
and women are decent honorable people
put themselves on the line
we owe them but the purpose
of my asking you here today is i want to
congratulate
the new secretary secretaries i'm going
to
take on an easy job nothing to it
homeland security
and and uh going to deal looking forward
to his leadership
and working with congress on a lot of
issues
including the immigration bill that has
i think great support in both chambers
today i'm going to sign a few executive
orders
to strengthen immigration system
building on
the executive actions i took on day one
to protect dreamers
and to end the muslim ban and to better
manage our borders
and that's what these three different
executive orders are about and i want to
make it clear
there's a lot of talk with good reason
about the number of executive orders
that i have signed
i'm not making new law i'm eliminating
bad policy
right um what i'm doing is taking on the
issues that
99 of them that the president the last
president united states
issued executive orders i thought were
very counterproductive to our security
counterproductive to who we are as a
country
particularly in uh in
the year of immigration this about how
america is safer stronger more
prosperous when we have a fair
orderly and humane legal immigration
system
and with the first action today
we're going to work to undo the moral
and national shame
of the previous administration that
literally not figuratively ripped
children from the arms of their families
their mothers and fathers at the border
tell us what's in it and with no
plan none whatsoever to reunify the
children who are still
in custody and their parents
the second action addresses the root
causes of our migration
to our southern border and the third
action
the third order i'm going to be signed
orders a full review
of the previous administration's harmful
and counterproductive immigration
policies basically across the board
and so with that i'm going to start in
the first order
i would love to flesh out what's in it
establishment of the
interagency task force and the
reunification of
families okay i mean the devil's in the
details it's an issue we need to deal
with
we'll have to see the full scope of the
order
reputation for what the separation has
caused
that is the first order
shouldn't he be holding them up like
this like trump does
second order i'm signing is creating a
comprehensive regional framework to
address the causes of migration
and to manage migration throughout the
north and central america
and to provide a safe and orderly
processing of asylum seekers
at the united states border
no sharpie or crayon even
wowza and
third order i'm signing
is restoring the faith in our legal
immigration system
and strengthening immigration and
inclusion efforts
for new americans
[Music]
my grandfathers say the grace of god and
the good will of the neighbors will
reunite these children and re-establish
our reputation as being a haven for
people in need
thank you very very much
to back up these reviews mr president
thank you
plenty of time thank you
thank you guys
all right
go right outside wow directly into the
cold
wow okay uh
oh my god where is that coming from oh
oh god there we go sorry about that guys
well a very very uh short event
um i don't know i don't know what else
to say
we we can't say they they said too much
that's for sure
um i i did want to get to this 50 super
chat happy birthday from a fellow
february fetus looking forward to your
next collab
with vosh comrade yeah i don't do the
comrade stuff i don't
i don't think of uh you know the soviet
era
as something to aspire to so those
aren't terms i use but i love the
support i really do
real quick i am seeing that we are very
cl
we've been talking about getting on
twitch to
7777
followers we're only 66 followers away
on twitch from 77
777. that's 7
7 7 7 7.
let's do it let's actually do it because
we are just
so so close and it's incredible
it's incredible what is going on i
appreciate
everybody who joined me on such a
special day
my birthday nikki cole celebrating nine
months of membership on twitch
with the message felix which i
appreciate
um but in all seriousness we will be
back
so soon and i will have so much more and
that's gonna do it for me for today
you